[Music]
all right
good night rest all right so let's play
let's play acaro let's play another karo
khan which we've been playing
uh quite often and knight d2
so as you guys have seen and those of
you who are like oh my god he's boring
you know what give give me a chance to
make it interesting alright
give me a chance to make it interesting
because if you want to be better at
chess
you have to embrace types of positions
that make you uncomfortable if you
only try to expose yourself to
aggressive positions or fun positions
you never get better at the stuff you
struggle with
so i'm going to play the the line that i
play that i have
that i've been playing quite often over
the past couple of months in my real
blitz games which is called the target
hour
so we take on e4 and now who can tell me
what the most popular move is after
knight takes for what is considered to
be the main line that's not what i play
what is the main line
so the main line is bishop f5 there is
also the move knight to d7 which is
considered to be the old-fashioned
main line but the move that has become
popular very recently and this move has
been around forever
but recently it's been picked up by very
very strong players including magnus is
knight to f6
which from an old-fashioned standpoint
is bad because we're
literally voluntarily ruining our pawn
structure
and of course g takes f6 is called the
bronze scene variation
that is considered to be very dubious
because it's just a little bit too
weakening but still interesting
the move e takes f6 is their tardic hour
variation
now after the game i'll guide you
through
some of the conceptual ideas here i
don't have the time to do that during
the game
but the bottom line here magnus did lose
to duda but he had a great position
it opens up the bishop and this bishop
we put first of all on
d6 that's a very natural developing move
now we castle also very natural
developing move and the way that he's
played it is already inaccurate
because it's allowed us to make a very
nasty move
very nasty developing move which is very
hard to deal with in these positions
what am i talking about
bishop g4 is right so we pin his knight
and you might say well what's so
what's so annoying about this you can
just go h3 and g4 that's obviously
tremendously weakening
and dropping the bishop back to e2 is
really really passive so
quite often this causes white a lot of
problems now we need to complete our
development and in the karo khan
as you know there's often a pun on c6 so
this knight should be developed to what
square
so this knight should be developed to
d7 of course now what
is the plan here now black's plan
frequently revolves around improving
the placement of this knight because
it's not very well placed on d7 first of
all we need to drop our bishop to h5
so often times if you've played the rail
lopez if you've played menu
in many openings you will see this plane
in action
so just by that one hint what am i
referring to
this plan exists for white in the rye
lopez
rookie 8 knight f8 and either knight g6
or knight e6
so that's one of the main ideas in this
line the secondary idea
is to centralize the knight via b6 so
you often go knight b6 and knight d5 and
it really depends on what white does
um you don't want to make any automatic
moves
now since i want to kind of emphasize
the main ideas of the line let's go
rookie 8 because it's a good move
regardless right
even if you don't play knight f8 uh
playing rookie 8 is obviously very good
because the rook is sort of on a
semi-open file so he goes bishop g4
that's kind of a creative idea
i'm not too familiar with this idea i've
never really seen it before myself
and this gives us a choice we can either
drop the bishop back or we can trade
bishops
but treating the bishop seems good from
the perspective of slightly weakening
his king
but i also want to emphasize the concept
of the pawn box
so let's go bishop g6 because in
addition to keeping the tension
it threatens what move what move is now
threatened
and he's got to play knight h4 here i
think in order to keep the balance
we're threatening the move f5 which
would trap the bishop does finite h are
very nice
and after knight takes g6 we're going to
take with the h bond and create a pawn
box which is one of my favorite pawn
structures i'm going to emphasize
and talk about why it's so good after
the game but for now
let's continue improving our position so
this knight on d7 we can go knight f8 we
can go knight b6 i like both of these
moves
i'm going to go knight b6 just because
it's a little bit more active
and then maybe put the knight on d5 now
what's another idea in
this position another idea thank you
chicken commander is to drop the bishop
back to c7 and follow up with what move
what does bishop c7 prepare we could
have also played bishop b8 in this
position but
it's a little bit awkward queen to d6
and something that you could notice if
your
tactical vision is good and here's the
pawn cube
after bishop c7 queen d6 if he plays
g3 to block the the battery
what tactic becomes possible this is
also part of the reason
why making contact with the bishop is
good rook takes e3 of course
and his pawn on f2 is simply overloaded
it's defending g3 and it's defending the
bishop
so that's something which we're gonna
get uh try to organize
and from that perspective knight d5 is
something that is a good idea to delay
why is it good to delay because if we
play knight t5 and he drops the bishop
back we no longer have this kind of
tactic this isn't really a gimmick it's
a legitimately good idea queen d6 and
he's already losing
he's already basically losing he's going
to play g3
then we play rook takes e3 and if he
plays f4
then we play uh rook takes e3 anyway now
i think you'd agree with me this was not
boring this is a fun line
and you can score many many nice
attacking wins in the tartar tower
now he can try c5 and that will allow us
to demonstrate a really beautiful tactic
what happens if you play c5
yeah simply rook takes g3 not hard to
find
blasting through the gates yes
we didn't really get to demonstrate why
the pawn cube is good but nonetheless
this was a nice game thank you gilan
yali for the 300.
okay queen e2 is a very good move very
good move that's i think the only way to
stay alive
for white wow that's a
that's a super good move now
uh to the concept that i talked about
previously
when you are attacking like this you
have to be very flexible as to how you
convert your advantage if we
if we play rook takes g3 stubbornly
after fg3 queen g3 notice that h2 is no
longer
accessible so he can just drop his king
back so we need to drop the rook back
now where do we drop it back well we
also need to be aware that his next move
is going to be c5 and he's going to win
the piece back
for a couple of puns so what we need to
do is prepare to take as
many pawns as possible provided that he
plays c5 so where should we put our rook
from that perspective and
at this point you have all the
information you need to answer the
question the move of course is rookie
four
yes and after c5 we can
take on d4 we'll have two extra pawns
and we'll be completely winning in the
end game even though it's an
opposite-colored bishop end game
when you're okay he doesn't do it he
just blunders yeah
now it's over even faster rook takes d4
kudos to him for finding queen d2 but
yeah bishop f3 is just
is just not the most resilient
okay so it would be very nice if we
could play rook e8 but we can't because
uh
that square is undefended so
he's no longer threatening c5 so we have
you know the opportunity to do whatever
we want
and there's many good moves here i like
the move rook to d2
although rook d2 has some sort of c5
tactic maybe
so ah but then we can move our queen
back but why bother
you know what i like is yeah queen d7 is
a great move to prepare a cube this
knight on b6 also is a little bit
annoying
because we no longer have access to the
d5 square
so if we identify our worst place piece
it's definitely the knight
let's bring our knight back to d7 in
order to centralize it
as i always say don't overthink these
things because there's a million good
moves
it's not like i'm finding the best move
necessarily or your move is bad
as long as you're making a move to
improve your position queen e5 was good
there
you're probably doing doing it right
also we can
reposition the bishop on b6 in order to
pin the king as you're indicating
queen e5 is very good as well okay rook
d1
we can take the rook but then we'd have
to be a little bit careful because
actually it's a very bad idea because
then he takes and he pins our knight
hey it's cap with ten damn girl oh my
goodness
this is ridiculous okay so what should
we do
how do we trade on our own terms assume
that his next move is rook takes d4
what piece do we want to land on d4
thank you so much hey it's cap
yeah it should be six as i indicated
previously is an excellent move
because rook d4 bishop d4 centralizes
the bishop threatens queen takes g3
and then we can bring our knight over to
e5
yeah we could have moved our rook to h4
but why
why be fancy like that that just asks
for trouble or talk about that after the
game
yeah nicely done okay
let me just write that down
okay king g2 he sees it
now again we don't have to take his rook
let him be the one to improve your
position now it's time to centralize our
knight with 95
yeah so again i'm not able to
demonstrate in this game why this is
good we won't need to
although maybe i'll hint at it
but nonetheless this is this is
important
and then we can play rogue d8 to control
fully the d-file
afterwards after he plays bishop b4
yeah of course obviously i'll explain
the pawn cube after the game
this is going to be an instructive sort
of
way to learn how to analyze pawn
structures and stuff so i hope you'll
enjoy that
okay so he plays there there he plays
rook c1 so he steps to side trying to
keep as many pieces as possible on the
board
okay so what to do what to do now
what to do ladies and gentlemen what to
do now
yeah rook d2 rook d2 we can play also f5
first but that's not necessary let's go
rook d2 that almost traps this queen
forces it back to e1
yeah nice easy easy play
easy play
yeah so one of the the analogies
that i like to give is that of a sort of
a snake shedding its skin okay it's a
little bit disgusting but still
let's centralize our queen queen d4 is a
good move here too piling up on the
f-pawn
we don't need to play f5 although we can
okay can we take this pawn
can we take this one
okay guys don't say no just because i'm
asking i love that kind of trick i asked
the question so people assume the answer
is no the answer is yes
because after rook c5 queen c5 our rooks
will be doubled on the default so our d2
rook will be defended
i'm trolling
and he resigns that was a nice game okay
so let's delve in knight d2 take stakes
knight f6
so when did this first arise
so the tardic hour is named after savile
tardikar was a
very famous sort of chess character he
was a gm but he also was famous for his
quotes and stuff
so this was first played by karo
literally the guy horatio caro after
whom the karakon is named
was the first person to play this line
in 1898 this just shows you that
people really knew what they were doing
and uh
target cower played it in 1911 and lost
played in 1914 lost again
and then he won so tardikara played it a
lot he won a couple lost a couple
win some lose some capoblanca played it
uh but it didn't really catch on until
like the 70s and 80s
and recently it's been having a
resurgence so
as you guys saw from the course of the
game knight f3 is not a mistake
it's couldn't even call it an inaccuracy
but it does give black an easier life
because it allows us to develop the
bishop to g4 and that's a beautiful
developing square or
white has to waste time going h3 and
creating a hook
so the cool people play c3
the point is to defend the pawn they
play bishop d3 and as you'll see from my
games
my blitz games everybody plays the move
queen c2 and the idea is very simple
you don't want to go knight f3 because
of bishop g4 so you get the queen away
from
d1 you force black to create a weakness
and after rookie a check
the knight develops to e2 and recently
people have been playing this very weird
looking move h5
this is uh you know this is a bit of a
hard move to explain like what are we
doing what is doesn't this look
self-destructive
and so the bottom line here is that h6
creates too many hooks
on the king's side so what is white's
long-term plan here going to be what
move is going to come with
tremendous effect later when white
prepares it
so white's going to go g4 h4 and g5 and
the moment that white goes g5
everything is going to explode on the
king's side right for example bishop b3
look at let's say knight d7 castles so
if black plays the same way that he does
with a pawn on h5 white can even
contemplate going g4
immediately because after bishop g4 rook
g1
the g file is open i think everybody
should see that this becomes extremely
unpleasant
and otherwise as soon as y goes g5
he makes things go boom the whole king
side sort of
explodes and certainly not to black's
favor
so this is very bad and so people came
up with the idea
of going h5 violating the rule obviously
about pushing pawns
in front of your king but the whole
point is that g4 is a lot harder to play
g4 is a much harder move to organize now
because you simply will play hg and that
doesn't open up the g
file it actually closes it so it's
this buys black time that he can use to
attack white's king
you might remember the game duda carlson
which was carlson's first loss in like
two years
but carlson had a great position here
and carlson played the
rare move b5 not fade as the main move
b5 is what carlson played
obviously starting the attack and
carving out the light squares so this
leads to a very sharp theoretical
position
but current theory dictates that black
is fine
but our opponent played here and at this
point already the position is equal
black is totally fine here now the way
that he played
h3 and bishop f5 we'll get to in a
second if
white plays c3 then as i indicated
rookie a knight f8 and knight g6
is the typical idea here and let me
introduce the concept of the pawn
cube by examining this structure
so why is the pawn on f6 actually kind
of good
and the analogy to the snake right a
snake sort of sheds its skin and then it
grows it back again
that's the key thing to understand here
about double puns when you push this
pawn up
which you might want to do to attack the
bishop or whatnot
what's left behind is a fully intact
pawn structure so you can do this
even with your king on the king's side
it assists you in attacking the king
it also stops knight g5 and knight e5 so
it's good as a standalone pawn
but this king is just tremendously safe
and so when you
when we have the pawn cube the same
exact concept comes into play
with even greater effect so for example
if we wanted to push the pawn
which we probably would have here let's
say we push f4 and g5 and we attack
guess what the king is still perfectly
safe okay we don't have an h pawn but
that's okay
because we have two of the pawns
remaining so that's the bottom line
that's
the that's the idea behind the pond cube
it's you can push
two of the pawns out for attacking
purposes without having to worry about
your king being weak
so that oversimplifies it but that's the
that's the basic principle and guess
what i mean look at how safe the king is
currently
now there is a drawback to that which is
that when you've got double pawns like
an end game would be bad for black
you know sometimes these pawns can be
clumsy but there's a lot that you gain
from having this as well
all right so b3 is very weakening he
weakens this square and we go bishop c7
we don't have to push the pawns because
we have the secondary idea of preparing
queen d6
so i think what should white have done
here it's already not that easy to
defend
rookie one would have been a possibility
because
now g3 is possible and the bishop is
defended
um and at this point i think f5 is a
great move
maybe f5 and queen h4 then rook d8 look
at the pressure on white's position here
just uh immense pressure here on white's
position
and black is definitely better so this
is a
more of a positional line than a
tactical line but there's certainly a
lot of tactics here i've beaten people
like ferrous here
pretty quickly as well with nice attacks
i'm also lost many games too
what about queen f3 you tell me what
happens if queen f3
what happens if queen f3
and again the pawning cube idea comes to
the rescue f5
traps the bishop and if white says all
right let me sack the let me sack the
bishop to open up the king
you ain't opening up anything because
the king is so well protected here
so this is yeah this is a one-of-a-kind
idea
so c4 queen d6 and white black is
already winning g3 rookie three
now if he played c5 here after rook
takes g3 king h1
we have a very pretty way to win the
game almost immediately
and i remember this it's funny because
rookie 3 rook g3
is a concept that i used to win a game
when i was like 1500.
let me see if i can find that game
so in 2004 i had a very similar
similar kind of concept you can play
rook rook g1 rook g1 is very pretty
rick takes g1 and queen h2 mate king
takes g10 so you can also play rook h3
that's also made in two
yeah so the concept of like just using
the rook and opening up a discovered
attack is very important okay so
queen d2 rookie four
um and he should have played c5
and after queen takes d4 white has some
chances
but honestly i would even take a takes
b6 to open up the a fall and tie down
the rook
then we would go rogue d2 we could get
the bishop into e5 and the pawn cube is
still pretty good in the end game
because of the idea of going f5 f4
um thank you
yeah almost a double cube if we had a
pawn like on c7 that would be hilarious
okay so all hail the pawn cube and after
bishop f3 rook d4 the
the game is over okay
so sudo moniker thank you for the prime
i appreciate it does anybody have
questions about this game
so now i think people are liking this
line quite a bit more
at a gm level you don't get a chance to
demonstrate all these ideas
unfortunately
but at like a 16 1700 level you can
definitely consider
playing this lineup of course why
doesn't have to play knight d2 why can
play the advanced car oh i can take on
d5 so
playing a line just because and i think
a lot of people do this there's one cool
variation that you really want to get
but you have to be okay with the other
variations you can't play an opening
just because there's one cool position
that you want to get
you want to be realistic and know what
you're doing in all of the lines
all right why would he let you get upon
cube well
a lot of people don't quite understand
how good it is and at this point
this knight on h4 has no other prospect
although maybe knight f5 was a good idea
but after bishop c7 were still
threatening to get a queen to d6 after
taking first
so the most challenging line of the
carcon i would say is the advance so
knight d2 is good
but the advance is the hardest to learn
there's a ton of theory
you guys have seen me play c5 here which
is my main
main line i still don't know this that
well but the main move is bishop f5
and this is tremendously theoretical
white has a million lines here
so this takes a lot of study but
realistically also the exchange car with
bishop d3 can be
quite a dangerous weapon if black is not
super accurate here
the fantasy is interesting too yeah the
fantasy has a bad reputation but it's
it's a very interesting line and mvl won
a game with it in the
in the candidates against alexenko so if
you're a tactical player you can
definitely take up the fantasy thank you
hot mom lover gifting to wonderbond
all right two nights is good too yeah
two nights has been very popular as well
um and if you play the tardic hour
against the two knights
white has this additional option queen
e2 which is what everybody plays now
obviously this is uh this is the idea
and just
sag but you've seen me take and go
knight d7 out of 6. so this is its own
theoretical line
there was a question about playing rook
h4 and this is just a point that i want
to make
um oh sorry rook takes d4 now queen h4
sometimes it's very tempting to make a
move just because
it's fancy right just because he can't
take on h4 you want to rub it in your
opponent's face but don't do that
because you can't assume your opponent's
dominant ooh i
just take the rook here the problem is
after rook 81
you're asking for trouble fortunately
black can go rook back to d4 but if you
didn't have this move black would
already be losing a rook
because you'd have to move your queen
and that would open up the possibility
of g takes h4 so if you're making a
fancy move
your first question should be is this
necessary your second question should be
are there any simpler alternatives
because the fancier the more
sophisticated the move
the better you feel about yourself but
the higher the probability that it's in
this calculation or a mistake
so it's a common misconception that i'm
like trying to play in a fancy way
i'm trying to make simple moves that i
know are correct
and only when they don't work do you
turn to fancy interesting tactical lines
so if you want to win more games
that should be your mentality i think
okay